big data
health informatics and bioinformatics
are some of the buzz words that you have
heard these days
what is bioinformatics why is it
important
and how can we use bioinformatics to
solve some of the problems that we face
every day these are some of the
questions that we will attempt to
address in this lecture
in 1799 while constructing a fort in
egypt
a group of french soldiers came across
an ancient egyptian tablet containing
hieroglyphics on it
what made the discovery of this tablet
later known as the rosetta stone
is so groundbreaking was not just the
fact that it contained hieroglyphics
at this point quite a few stones without
a known translational script
had already been discovered it was the
greek version which came with the
hieroglyphics that made the stone so
important to scholars
for over a thousand years no one has
been able to read the ancient egyptian
script
but everyone trained in classical
languages could read greek
this discovery enabled the scholars to
find a way to decode the meaning of the
hieroglyphics
the symbols which have been silent for
over a millennium became a new window
into ancient egyptian life and culture
today we are faced with a challenge and
an opportunity similar to that of the
rosetta
stone it comes from a language which
works in any human language in the
immense number of volumes written in it
and that is the language of dna
dna contains the blueprints for every
biological process of every living thing
on earth
and even a small defect in the genetic
code can cause devastating health
consequences
understanding how genes work both
individually and with each other is
crucial to the development of 21st
century personalized medicine
however the problem is that even when we
actually have an
organism's dna in front of us it is not
possible to sift through it without an
army of people to understand
it it is often not easy to tell what an
individual gene does
even more difficult is to tease out the
subtle influences that multiple genes
have on each other
but answering those kinds of questions
is foundational to
attacking the root cause of genetically
influenced diseases
today new high-throughput technologies
bring unprecedented opportunities for
life science research
they allow us to get new data never seen
before to study new questions impossible
to study before
and to discover new phenomena
unimaginable before
now we can sequence not only one
person's genome but also many different
people's genomes
this allows us to study the genetic
differences between different people at
genome scale
as well as many other questions in
population genetics
at the same time we can also study the
genetic differences between patients
and normal controls to find the genetic
mutations responsible for some of the
diseases
in addition to the human genome over 1
000 trillion base pairs from over 165
000 species had been sequenced by the
end of 2013
just reading them would take 30 million
years
life science data is not only big in
size but also growing exponentially
this figure shows the number of
nucleotides sequenced and stored in the
genbank database over the years
the number of nucleotides had been
increasing exponentially since 1982
doubling every 20 months what does this
mean
it means that the data deposited into
genbank in the next 20 months from now
on
is as much as all the data that have
existed in the history of humans till
today
at the same time the sequencing cost had
been decreasing every year
the past few years had seen even steeper
growth of sequencing data
the reason is that next generation
sequencing technologies had been
developed and used more and more widely
in all areas of life sciences
next generation sequencing technologies
can sequence one person's genome in a
day with less than two thousand dollars
just think about what exciting
discoveries these never seen before data
may contain
other than sequencing data other high
throughput
such as proteomic metabolomic and etc
had also generated a large variety of
data
with great opportunities come great
challenges
the huge amount of data requires
efficient methods
exponential growth requires scalable
methods
the low signal to noise ratio requires
accurate methods
and handling multiple types of data
requires data integrative methods these
are significant technical challenges
but it depends on how you look at it
technical challenges can also mean
opportunities for technical innovations
the birth and growth of the field of
bioinformatics has been driven
by these opportunities and challenges
as you may be able to realize by now the
integration between life science and
computer science is inevitable
and the result is the birth and growth
of the field of bioinformatics
bioinformatics can be defined as an
interdisciplinary field that develops
and applies computer and computational
technologies to study biomedical
questions
it has two roles as a technology
bioinformatics is a powerful technology
to manage
search and analyze big data in life
sciences
as a methodology bioinformatics is a
top-down holistic
data-driven genome-wide and systems
approach that generates new hypotheses
finds new patterns and discovers new
functional elements
it complements traditional experimental
biology methods
a seamless combination of computational
and experimental methods
should be the best way to study a
biological question
bioinformatics is truly
interdisciplinary
it studies questions in biology and
medicine while developing and applying
methods in computer sciences
mathematics statistics and physics
it overlaps with medical and clinical
informatics systems biology
and synthetic biology
the bio and bioinformatics signifies the
biological questions it studies
many of which can be grouped under the
conceptual framework from genotype to
phenotype and the central dogma
some examples may help you understand
better
for instance sequence alignment are the
sequences of two genes or proteins
similar
could they be homologous how can we find
the closest homolog of the gene we are
studying from the vast databases
can i use the known function of a known
gene to guide the study of my gene of
interest
given dna and genome sequences how can
we find the genes in the vast genome
how can we compare the similarity and
difference between two whole genomes and
reconstruct the evolutionary history
what are the synthetic regions between
two genomes
how can we identify which genomic
regions are methylated
at the level of rna expression we often
need to find out which genes are
differentially expressed between two
organs or tissues
between tumor and normal tissues or
between two different developmental
stages
at the level of proteins how do you
identify the expressed proteins from
mass spec data
proteins do not exist in a linear form
in nature
instead they are folded into beautiful
three-dimensional structures in nature
how can we predict the three-dimensional
structure of a protein from its sequence
molecules do not exist or function in
isolation
instead they form complex molecular
network
how can we construct protein protein
interaction networks
transcription regulation networks and
metabolic and signaling pathways
what are the dynamic features of these
networks
furthermore with these data and
researches how can we simulate a virtual
cell
last but not least how do you compare
different people's genomes and use
population genetic approaches to compare
the genomes of the ill and the healthy
and identify the gene mutations that
cause diseases
from these examples we can see that
there are many interesting and important
questions in life sciences that await
our bioinformatics investigation
seeing bioinformatics from another angle
the informatics in bioinformatics
signifies the information in
computational methods to manage
search and analyze the data the theme
runs along the axis from data to
discovery
first the storage index and search of
terabytes to petabytes of big data
require advanced databases
just imagine your laptop probably has
several gigabytes of hard disk
however just one set of our experiments
often generates one or more terabytes of
data
which is too large to fit in your laptop
managing such big data requires advanced
database systems
analysis of noisy big data requires the
development of many
algorithms software tools and web
servers
these make up a big portion of
bioinformatics research
a tradition in bioinformatics since the
early days till today has been to make
most
algorithms and software open source this
has contributed significantly to the
broader life science research
and had helped to advance bioinformatics
itself as well
with these tools we can do a lot of data
mining to discover new patterns and
phenomena in life science
finally by integration of data and tools
we can build predictive models of
biological systems
as more and more high throughput
technologies are used more and more in
life science
there will continue to be numerous new
opportunities for technology innovation
in bioinformatics
to meet this challenge a new breed of
professional that could collaborate and
communicate with biomedical researchers
clinicians quantitative scientists and
bioethicists is needed to translate the
genomic knowledge to improve patient
outcomes
in summary bioinformatics is central to
molecular life science research